en este vídeo tengo toda la intención de
ver cómo se factorizar algunas
cuadráticas y para esto me tomé estos
dos ejemplos que tengo aquí pero antes
de resolver estos dos ejercicios que
tengo aquí es muy importante que
recordemos lo siguiente me gustaría
recordar cómo se veían las siguientes
multiplicaciones de binomios si yo me
tomaba x + am y lo quería multiplicar
por x + b que me daba el resultado bueno
x por x le va a dar x 4 y después me va
a quedar x por ver más a por x esto es
lo mismo que a x más bx o dicho de otra
manera a más b que multiplica x y
después me quedaría para finalizar a por
bueno si yo lo que quiero es factorizar
estos dos trinomios a una forma de este
estilo
entonces me tengo que fijar en dos cosas
primero que el que está multiplicando a
x es a más b es decir me fijo en dos
números que sumados me den el número que
esté al lado de la equis y después me
tengo que fijar en a por b es decir dos
números que multiplicados me den el
término libre y como los voy a encontrar
bueno
el primer ejemplo tengo x cuadrada menos
14 x es decir que tengo que a más b
tiene que ser igual a menos 14 que es el
término que está al lado de la equis y
después tengo que abordé tendrá que ser
igual a 40 por b es igual a 40 que es el
término libre este de aquí que no tiene
a equis y por lo tanto ya tengo un
sistema de ecuaciones o podría pensar un
poquito en dos números que multiplicados
me den 40 y que sumados me den menos 14
y primero me fijo que es 10 por 4 pero
10 por 4 sumados no me dan menos 14 por
lo tanto necesito que sean dos números
negativos tales que al multiplicarse me
dé un resultado positivo y sumados me
den un número negativo por lo tanto me
voy a tomar a menos 4 y menos 10 menos 4
más menos 10 es lo mismo que menos 14 y
menos 4 por menos 10 es lo mismo que 40
positivo y súper chévere porque ya los
encontré pero espérame tantito antes de
locarno sé cantar victoria me gustaría
que te fijarás en lo siguiente si en la
multiplicación de estos dos números mi
resultado es positivo entonces estos
tienen que tener el mismo signo si mi
resultado es negativo esto quiere decir
que entonces mis dos números tienen que
ser de signos contrarios sin embargo en
este caso como obtuve que mi suma tiene
que ser negativa no me queda de otra
mis dos números me tienen que salir
ambos negativos y entonces este trinomio
lo puedo ver de la siguiente forma x
menos 4 que multiplica a x + menos 10 o
dicho de otra manera y esta es la manera
que me gusta más x menos 4 por x menos
10 es lo mismo que x cuadrada menos 14
más 40 así que vamos a fijarnos en el
segundo ejemplo para ver si entendemos
mucho mejor a hamás b la suma de estos
dos términos tiene que ser igual al
término que está lado de la x que es
menos uno menos uno por x me da menos x
entonces a más b es igual a menos 1 y
por otra parte a por b me tiene que dar
igual a menos 12 entonces por b es igual
a menos 12 y ahora sí vamos a
preguntarnos en dos números que
multiplicados me den menos 12 y que
sumados me den menos 1 como nos damos
cuenta que el resultado de la
multiplicación es negativo entonces
tienen que tener diferente
signo uno tiene que ser positivo y el
otro negativo entonces dos números que
multiplicados me den 12 12 por 16 por 24
y 34 y 3 me dan 12 y 4 y 3 cuando me
tomo la diferencia entre ellos me da 1 o
menos uno pero cómo quiero que mi
resultado sea menos 1 entonces voy a
decir que 3 más menos 4 es igual a menos
1 y por otra parte 3 x menos 4 es igual
a menos 2 y ya aquí tengo mis dos
números que son mis raíces que me van a
ayudar a factorizar a este trinomio que
tengo aquí arriba date cuenta como estos
dos números si me funcionan porque 3 más
menos 4 o 3 menos 4
es lo mismo que menos 1 y por otra parte
3 x menos 4 es lo mismo que 12 negativo
y entonces ya encontré dos números que
sumados media menos 1 y que al
multiplicarse me dan menos 12 y entonces
ya puedo factorizar el tri nombre que
tenía que arriba como x + 3 que
multiplica a x más menos 4 o mejor aún x
menos 4